So Changmin, when you weren't out for hiking, what were you doing in Korea?
You mean, what did I do most of the time?
Exactly!
Well, when I was a student, I spent most of my time playing basketball.
I see. Were you involved in any clubs at your school?
Actually, I was a member of the newspaper club.
I worked as a writer for my school's newspaper.
No kidding! That sounds really interesting! What kind of things did you write about?
Mostly school affairs. I was in charge of covering our school's election.
Election?
Yes. I wrote articles about each of the major candidates;...
...what their opinions were, what they were like as students, and so on.
That must have been a lot of fun.